feuerinferno hier in berlin ein
munitionslager der polizei in flammend
hier in der hauptstadt im grunewald
wenn wir ein so breites mitten in der
nacht
eine riesige explosion weltkriegs
funktion illegale böller entschärfte
bombe all das dort gelagert und so hat
es geknallt und man weiß noch nicht was
die brandursache war wie genau das
passieren konnte diese mega explosion
seit den frühen morgenstunden geht das
so seit kurz vor 4 uhr immer wieder
detonationen explosion und damit sind
die berliner dort im süden der stadt
aufgewacht mehr als 100 feuerwehrleute
versuchen den brand im grunewald gerade
zu bekämpfen mittlerweile ist auch die
bundeswehr mit panzern im einsatz hilft
der feuerwehr und all das hier bei
temperaturen über 35 grad in der
waldstadt und schauen wir uns diesen
sprengplatz einmal genauer an wenn genau
dort hinter diesem zaun dort hat es
geknallt und so sieht das dort aus auf
diesem gelände befinden sich bis zu 50
tonnen sprengmaterial hier sehen wir den
blick auf diesen sprengplatz aus dem
jahr 2015 dieser aus aufnahme ist
natürlich umzäunt mit stacheldraht
gesichert die feuerwehr die bezeichnet
die lage immer noch als unübersichtlich
das feuer das breite sich unkontrolliert
aus die einsatzkräfte die kämen wegen
der auf dem sprengplatz gelagerte
munition nicht näher dran als 1000 meter
an den brand ja und es gibt auch ein
entscheidendes hilfsmittel für die
einsatzkräfte ein kleiner helfer da ist
theodor ein ferngesteuerter hier sehen
wir ein roboter der bundeswehr der wird
jetzt dort eingesetzt um näher an den
brandherd heranzukommen die lage besser
einschätzen zu können die bundeswehr
diesen roboter eigentlich bei der
kampfmittel abwehr in deutschland aber
auch bei auslandseinsätzen in
afghanistan zum beispiel hat das
sprengfallen aufgespürt vier kameras at
oder und ein greifarm und jetzt jetzt
hilft er dort im grunewald weiter aus
und auch das sind bilder dieses tages
die komplett leere war gesperrt davos
nichts geht mehr zu nah dran am rand
dieser autobahn es ist ein mega brand
hier in berlin grunewald und das feuer
bisher weiterhin
unlesbar das dramatische munition und
explosionen machen es der feuerwehr
diesen einsatz besonders schwer
was sie hier hören sind explosionen
heftige explosionen auf einem
sprengplatz mitten in deutschland im
berliner grunewald nur wenige kilometer
vom zentrum der hauptstadt vom
brandenburger tor entfernt
dort wo sich berliner familien am
wochenende mit ihren kindern erholen
riecht gegen 3.30 die hölle los uhr
plötzlich explodiert auf dem sprengplatz
munition durchbricht die nächtliche
stille immer wieder knallt es mit diesem
geräusch machen tausende berliner am
donnerstagmorgen auch noch in der nacht
eintreffende einsatzkräfte berichten von
tonnen schweren stahlträgern die ihnen
um die ohren fliegen feuerwehr polizei
und bundeswehr können sich dem feuer nur
auf 1000 meter nähern es besteht
lebensgefahr
auf dem sprengplatz lagern bis zu 50
tonnen munition
die extreme trockenheit wirkt wie ein
brandbeschleuniger
das feuer breitet sich rasend schnell
aus mittlerweile stehen 1,5 hektar also
rund 15.000 quadratmeter des hauptstadt
waldes in brand ein weiteres problem die
hitze ist so 38 grad in berlin das
erschwert die löscharbeiten zusätzlich
aktuell sind 100 einsatzkräfte vor ort
fahren räumpanzer und wasserwerfer auf
aber machen sich aus der luft einen
überblick von der lage die feuerwehr
bewässert nun in einem radius von 1000
metern um das feuer den wald so soll
eine weitere ausbreitung des feuers
verhindert werden die anwohner sind
sicher ist ins wohngebiet kommt das
feuer nicht der schreck sitzt dennoch
tief über explosionen hier in
deutschland in berlin vor unserer
haustür
wir wollen jetzt direkt an den
einsatzort gehen er mein kollege peter
hell dort vor ort auch immer wieder in
kontakt mit allen die dort den einsatz
begleiten den einsatz leiten zum
beispiel auch mit polizeisprecher t
lokales was sind peter die neuesten
erkenntnisse
ja das neueste was ich berichten kann
hier von dem schauplatz hier ist das
vorhin vor wenigen minuten die
regierende bürgermeisterin von berlin
franziska giffey eingetroffen ist sie
ist in einen wagen eingestiegen und
begutachtet jetzt die situation soweit
sie soweit sie rankommen kann
das ist ein kreis von 300 metern bis
dahin wird sie wohl ran kommen das ist
dahinter nicht wohl mehr möglich sie
macht sich einen eindruck und sie hat
eben auch
gesagt dass die ereignisse sehr
dramatisch sind und dass berlin ein
derartiges ereignis seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg eben noch nicht erlebt hat und
auch sie steht natürlich auch vor den
großen fragezeichen sie konnte auch
nicht sagen wie es zu diesen ursachen
kommt aber sie sagten natürlich auch das
zurzeit eben kein keine gefahr für die
bevölkerung besteht das nächste haus sei
eben zwei kilometer von dem hotspot
entfernt hier ist ein kreis ein
sicherheits kreis von 1000 metern
gezogen worden und ich möchte eben den
sprecher der berliner polizei
thilo kabel jetzt noch mal dazu fragen
wie ist das eingeteilt wie muss man sich
das vorstellen was die sicherheit
anbelangt grundsätzlich liegt das
natürlich der verantwortung der
feuerwehr die nach dem ersten überblick
über die situation gesagt wir ziehen
hier unterschiedliche sperrkreises auch
in beratung mit den sprengmeistern von
uns es gibt einen zentralen sperrkreis
in höhe von 300 metern rund um den
ereignisort dann eben diesen 1000 meter
sperrkreis den wir als sicherheitspuffer
sicherheitszone einrichten mussten und
haben sie schon erkenntnis darüber um
welche sprengkörper es sich handelt und
wie sind die gesichert falls die
angegriffen werden von den flammen
natürlich haben wir einen überblick ein
sehr präzisen überblick über die
sprengmittel und kann flüge die dort
abgelegt werden es geht ja auch darum
dass sie dann geeignet vernichtet werden
auch das wird alles entsprechend
protokolliert so dass wir sagen können
25 tonnen sprengmittel liegen da 300
kilogramm pyrotechniker beschlagen kann
unter diesen sprengmitteln wirklich das
gesamte portfolio von munition für
schusswaffen bis hin zu der 500 kilo
weltkriegsbombe zu diese bomben haben
wir gehört sieht eben in speziellen
behältern gesichert sind die sicher vor
den flammen die sind grundsätzlich
gesichert selbstverständlich jetzt muss
man natürlich gucken wie sich das feuer
weiter entwickelt irgendwann wird dann
auch ein feuer für andere gegenstände
hat sich oder für sowas auch gefährlich
aber grundsätzlich sind sie gesichert
und man darf auch nicht vergessen sie
sind ja erst einmal entschärft das heißt
der zünder ist nicht mehr in diesen
fliegerbomben bringen
sondern da ging es ja eben darum dass
die vor ort entschärft wurden das heißt
der zünder abonnenten und dann wurden
sie erst hierher transportiert können
sie denn damit oder können sie
ausschließen dass weitere maßnahmen
ergriffen werden oder dass der
sicherheitsradius erweitert wird zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt würde ich nichts
ausschließen wollen es geht ganz klar
darum dass wir die lage immer weiter
beurteilen aktuell geht es ja auch darum
um diesen schaffens roboter also den
wirtschaftsfonds roboter den wir ran
führen dass wir mit diesem einen
überblick erhalten um einschätzen zu
können wo gibt es brandherde die
tatsächlich noch gefährdungspotenzial
bilden gefährdungspotenzial haben und
dann die feuerwehr dahingehend beraten
können sodass momentan wirklich noch
alles offen ist und letzten endes auch
immer wieder und das betont gerne halt
in der verantwortung das ist einmal der
feuerwehr die hier die einsatzleitung
hat wie unterstützen vielen dank herr
kafitz wir haben gerade gehört dieser
sicherheits kreis diese no go area das
ist 300 meter um das um diesen hot spot
wo eben diese munition lagert da darf im
moment nur roboter theodor ein wir haben
es heute mittag schon gehört von dem
general von dem einsatzleiter general
mann er hat beschrieben dass dieser
roboter mit vier kameras ausgestattet
ist und eben
gefahrlos quasi in dieses gefahrengebiet
reinfahren kann übermittelt dann live
die bilder er hat ein heber arm der 20
kilo aufheben kann transportieren kann
man kann bodenproben damit entnehmen und
man kann eben ohne gefahr so nah wie
möglich an dieses an diesen hot spot
herankommen so dass eben die
einsatzkräfte genau wissen wie die
situation vor ort aussieht hier sehen
wir wieder ein hubschrauber der reicht
von der bundespolizei das geht hier im
minutentakt dann versucht man eben auch
von der luft aus zu löschen ich möchte
auch noch kurz mal zeigen hier dieser
dieses tank gefäß diese tankbehälter die
errichtet die polizei beziehungsweise
die feuerwehr jetzt im grunewald über
all das sind im prinzip reservoirs wo
sich die feuerwehrautos wie wir sehen
jetzt hier rechts in den wald rein
fahren auch bedienen können so dass man
ununterbrochen eben löschwasser
entnehmen kann um eben auch die
randgebiete zu bewässern das ist ja die
große gefahr und die große angst eben
hier dass die randgebiete die pulver
trocken sind hier im wald eben feuer
fangen um daneben möglicherweise auf die
nahe liegenden wohnhäuser übergreifen
können peter heller sich fast auch noch
mal zu diesem zeitpunkt zusammen bisher
das haben wir jetzt auch irgendwas von
dem gespräch kilo kabels gehört kann man
nicht ausschließen dass es dort zu
weiteren explosionen kommende wird das
kann man zu diesem zeitpunkt nicht
ausschließen wenn man auch auf das
reservoir dort schaut was dort alles
versammelt es unter anderem 500 kilo
weltkriegsbomben aber auch munition
feuerwerkskörper illegale natürlich ist
das alles endlich also in sicherheit im
sinne von nicht mehr quasi hochgehe
bereit aber dennoch das feuer kann da
einiges anrichten diese situation ist im
moment noch nicht abschätzbar und auch
weiterhin kommt die feuerwehr nicht so
richtig ran dazu die temperaturen
staubtrocken die bundeswehr die
unterstützt jetzt das heißt bereits
angesprochen wie und in welchem umfang
darüber hast du ja mit general jürgen
kortmann gesprochen dass uns da
gemeinsam noch einmal reinschauen
wunderbar ich begrüße jetzt nehmen wir
ein general hartmann
bucht man entschuldigung herr general
der general sie sind gerade eingetroffen
wir haben gerade den bergepanzer büffel
gesehen wie sind sie jetzt unterwegs was
machen sie jetzt im grunewald hat können
sie machen was kann die bundeswehr
machen also um mal den bergepanzer
aufzunehmen der wird nach maßgabe der
feuerwehr und entsprechender einweisung
zur brandschneisen schlagen oder aber
auch zum räumen eingesetzt dort wo
fläche gebraucht hat um zb
einsatzfahrzeuge hin zu bringen weil er
das gut und schnell kann
was können sie uns zur munition sagen
warum nicht da so viel munition noch aus
dem zweiten weltkrieg und wie sicher ist
die diese frage geben sie bitte weiter
an die polizei das kann ich ihnen nicht
sagen alles was ich dazu weiß
kommt aus reiseführern ganz ehrlich da
fragen sie den falschen nochmal die
soldaten sind vor ort ihre männer sind
vor ort was können sie jetzt konkret
machen wie können sie die
feuerwehrkräfte unterstützen mit dem
schweren gerät die wir unterstützen mit
dem schweren gerät noch mal mit dem
schlagen von brandschneisen da wo die
feuerwehr sie für notwendig hielt und
räumen von anderem
infrastruktur gewächs bäume wo immer die
feuerwehr sagt das was getan werden soll
und notwendig ist und darüber hinaus
unterstützen wir vor allen dingen mit
aufklärungs fähigkeit mit diesem
kampfmittelbeseitiger manipulator namens
theodor der nach maßgabe der feuerwehr
an den brandherd heran gebracht wird
fern gelenkt um noch ein möglichst
genaues lagebild am ort bekommen da wo
menschen nicht mehr hin laufen kann das
heißt er hat quasi eine kamera und kann
visuell ihnen sagen wie es aus er hat
vier kameras einen einen ausleger so
dass man auch höhe gewinnen kann er hat
kettenantrieb kann durch unwegsames
gelände gebracht werden und die experten
sind gerade dabei den einsatz dieses
gerätes vor ort abzusprechen und dann
möglich zu machen general wer hat die
bundeswehr angefordert wie war da die
befehlskette da gibt es keine
befehlskette sondern die feuerwehr und
wir stehen bereits seit kurz nach
mitternacht in verbindung und ganz
konkret hat mich der landesbrandmeister
herr doktor homrighausen heute morgen um
kurz nach sechs mit konkreten fähigkeit
forderungen angerufen die haben wir
aufgenommen und erfüllen die gerade also
sie können als bundeswehr ohne befehl
quasi selbstständig in die gefahrenzone
reingehen wenn sie angefordert werden
von der feuerwehr das hier ist nothilfe
für nothilfe gibt es ganz klar
gesetzlich geregelt und abgesicherte
verfahren und im rahmen dieses
gesetzlichen rahmens befinden wir uns
hier rechnen diese auch mit größeren
einsatzkräften ihrerseits oder mit noch
mehr panzern falls es außer kontrolle
geraten könnte das liegt in der hand der
feuerwehr das zu beurteilen wir stehen
bereit und fordert die feuerwehr weitere
fähigkeiten der bundeswehr an dann
werden wir diese bereitstellen und wie
viel man sitzen hier im moment sind wir
mit etwa 20 mann und frau hier aber noch
mal die zahl der personen ist nicht
entscheiden das gerät macht den
unterschied
jetzt ist er wieder bei mir peter hell
wenn man die situation derzeit so
beobachtete das feuer weiterhin
eigentlich unlösbar immerhin noch nicht
klar wie viel dort noch explodiert kann
es aus seiner sicht sei es für möglich
dass da der grunewald mehr oder weniger
abbrennt gutmenschen leben nicht in
gefahr dennoch es ist eine basis er
gehört zu berlin wie der alex die
berliner lieben dieses
naherholungsgebiet und jetzt dieser
massive brand brandwolken rauchwolken
über der hauptstadt wie weit kann es
gehen
naja das der grunewald abbrennt das ist
jetzt nicht so unmöglich also das feuer
hat hier die besten voraussetzungen es
ist pulver trocken wir haben 36 grad im
moment man merkt es wird auch ein
bisschen windig jetzt hier also das sind
alles voraussetzungen das kennen wir ja
aus den waldbrandgebieten aus
brandenburg wie schnell das geht und das
ist eben die große gefahr dass so was
außer kontrolle geraten kann ja das muss
man ganz klar mit ja beantworten die
gefahr besteht dass es hier sich
ausweitet und dann sieht die sache hier
ein bisschen anders aus wenn man sich
überlegt wie riesig der grunewald ist
eigentlich kilometer lang zieht sich das
hier trocken an berlin um berlin herum
also das ist nicht ganz abwegig und das
ist genau die geschichte die situation
warum die feuerwehr eben um diesen
brandherd alles feucht macht um eben
eine ausweitung eines brandes zu
verhindern dass eben hier nicht noch ein
riesiges feuer ein wald ein flächenbrand
entsteht der dann womöglich auch an die
wohngebiete heranreichen könnte peter
hell mit den neuesten informationen zum
feuerinferno im berliner grunewald
vielen herzlichen dank dir die
voraussetzungen das haben wir gerade
gehört die sind nicht gut es ist über 35
grad hier in berlin leichter wind und
der boden in den wäldern der ist
komplett trocken ja welche gefahr geht
von diesem feuer jetzt aus darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit brandexperte dr
ulrich thiem mulino ist leiter des
arbeitskreises waldbrand ganz herzlich
willkommen schön dass sie bei uns sind
sagen sie wie schätzen sie die situation
einer warum ist dieser brannte schwierig
zu löschen und wie gefährlich ist so
eine situation
ja ich bin ja wie wir gehört munition in
verschiedenen größenordnungen taliban
und dazu nur feuerwerkskörper in einem
umfang der mit der gesamtmenge von 25
tonnen ziemlich große sich vermutlich
ein teil davon wird sein das problem
beim munition ist immer egal ob das
jetzt der sprengplatz ist oder
fundmunition in einem clip übungsplatz
oder aber ehemaligen kampffläche oder
auf einer ehemaligen munitionsdepot
aktion städte nach dem krieg den
gesprächen wurde ist immer das gleiche
sobald die munition gefunden wird der
sperrkreis sicherheitsglas verhängt von
den kampfmittelräumung und gesperrt ist
auch die feuerwehr nicht rein weil die
folge hat keine geschützten fahrzeuge
und geht ab herbst nicht ungeschützt vor
wir haben jetzt eben gehört der stärker
als es in diesem fall betretungsverbot
300 meter das ist schon eher als die
anfangs veröffentlichten 1000 meter aber
selbst bei 300 meter hatte vor über
keinerlei chance an das eigentliche
voranzukommen die burg weiten von
unseren geräten liegen maximal im
bereich mit werfer vielleicht 50 60
meter dann darüber hinaus höchstens das
wundergerät aber 300 meter wird damit
auch nicht erreicht das heißt wir haben
keine möglichkeit das vorher direkt
aktiv zu bekämpfen mit den üblichen
einsatzmöglichkeiten die normale
feuerwehren zu haben also dass auch eine
sehr gefährliche situation für die
feuerwehrmänner und frauen die dort dann
im einsatz sind wenn sie überhaupt daran
dürfen im moment versucht man sich ja
noch einen überblick zu verschaffen was
dort im zentrum des brandes überhaupt
los ist wie gefährlich halten sie die
situation dass sich dieses feuer weiter
ausbreitet ich hab das eben beschrieben
hier in berlin ist es knallheiß der
boden ist staubtrocken und die feuerwehr
kann nichts anderes tun als zu schauen
dass im umkreis die landschaft feucht
gehalten wird
also zunächst nur die politik haben
alles richtig gemacht als sie beim
eintreffen merkt haben was da drinnen
und die ersten internationalen sich
erhoffen sich die zurückgezogen das war
die einzige richtige entscheidung
und jetzt haben wir die lage es gibt
diesen sperrkreis ist ein sicherheits
kreis darum herum bildet offensichtlich
mit unterstützung der bundeswehr
schneise gezogen das ist auch eine
völlig richtige maßnahme die immer
wieder so gemacht wird und an dieser
sperrzone an dieser grenze von den
sperren kann man auch dieses feuer
tatsächlich stoppen ich denke das wird
die feuerwehr berlin mit unterstützung
der beteiligten gut schaffen können die
wetterlage selber ist im augenblick
natürlich noch sehr trocken es wird
nacht vielleicht ein bisschen regnen
allerdings morgen könnte der wind zu
nehmen also man sich die
wettervorhersagen können wunderbar zu
anschaut dann ist morgen bis windstärke
fünf möglich und bis dahin sollte man
eine lösung haben weil dieser stark
gewinnt natürlich dazu führt dass
besorgen kann das blut funken über
diesen sicherheitsbereich mit den
studenten schneisen hinweg getragen wird
und dann hinterher großes problem
entsteht also wieder zu raten möglichst
die schneisen schnell zuschlagen
und dann vorher versuchen an diesen
stellen zu halten das machen die
kollegen jetzt auch und sonst kann man
eigentlich fast nichts machen die
einzige chance werden auch in das gebiet
reinzufahren mit geschützten fahrzeugen
also mit in diesem fahrzeug der der
bundespolizei oder der polizei
allerdings haben diese fahrzeuge die
wasserwerfer der polizei er nur ein
schutz gegen klein waschen und da
müssten die vorher werke entscheiden ob
das möglich ist damit rein zu fahren
wenn das nicht möglich sein sollte geht
es nur mit panzern und davon gibt es
eigentlich in deutschland über eine
privat immer welche da kann man es
versuchen das feuer in der im kern zu
bekämpfen aber darf man nicht aussteigen
also das ist ein großes problem was wir
auf diesen munitions flächen haben egal
ob sprengplatz oder halt freifläche und
haben viel zu viele von diesen flächen
und der job der nächsten jahre
jahrzehnte wäre es endlich dafür zu
sorgen dass die flächen gründen hat
simon eder letzte frage stellt sich das
so einfach vorschnell löschhubschrauber
drüber schicken wasser abwerfen und
versuchen den brand einzudämmen ist dass
irgendeine option die sind so sagt man
überall anders unterwegs und können gar
nicht eingesetzt werden wir haben gar
nicht genug offenbar auch hier in
deutschland und auch daran hängende
frage noch an sie was glauben sie
wielange wird uns dieses feuer begleiten
wenn ich ihren schilderungen zu hören
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass das
in den nächsten 24 stunden wirklich
eingedämmt gar gelöscht werden kann
also beginnen bei der hubschrauber das
ist ein problem zurzeit haben sehr viele
parallelen stellen in ganz deutschland
sind gestern mal wieder in nrw welche
wir haben jetzt noch mehrere neue
stellen in im osten dazu bekommen heute
das mit grunde weit die häufung ist
relativ groß und wir haben insgesamt zu
wenig und so wenig leistungsfähige
helikopter
das problem ist wenn sie eine munitions
verdachtsfläche haben dann wird der
sperrkreis verhängt das ist nicht nur
radio ist das ist wäre das eine
halbkugel stellt sie eine käseglocke vor
und oberhalb des radios muss der
hubschrauber auch verbleiben das heißt
wenn jetzt 1000 meter oder 500 meter und
1 300 meter verengt wird dann gibt es in
der höhe auch und wenn sie als 1000
liter wasser abwerfen kommt am boden gar
nichts als 300 meter wasser werfen
kommen käppchen
die wirksamkeit bis bei diesen abwurf
gegen null wenn sie tiefer fliegen
wollten bräuchten sie hubschrauber die
gegen splitter werden von unten
geschützt sind da musste man mit den
bundesräten ob sie so etwas haben und ob
diese diese munition gelagert wird damit
verträglich ist das müssen die krank
mittleren schärfer definieren aber an
sich ist der hubschrauber ein nicht
wirklich besseres mittel weil das warst
du nur von oben runter bringen und damit
die glutnester erwischt also es bleibt
auch dann noch an schlussmann muss
tatsächlich irgendwann reingehen und das
vorher bekannt dass machen dafür muss
man zusammenarbeit mit der kompletten
diensten muss man mit den bundesräten
und hat mit spezialisten die vielleicht
schützt ihr fahrzeug ab und fahren zu
können damit das vorher begrenzt platte
um vor dem nächsten winter möglichst aus
ist
ganz ganz nach ihrer antwort auf meine
letzte frage ich habe nicht den eindruck
dass das so schnell unter kontrolle
gelöscht ist dieses feuer innerhalb der
nächsten 24 stunden ich weiß es ein
bisschen der blick in die glaskugel aber
sie kennen sich aus mit solchen lagen
mit solchen großlagen was glauben sie
schwierig einzuschätzen weil ich ja
nickt man nicht mal genau weiß wie groß
die fläche von 15 hektar der gewalt hat
eine fläche von 3000 hektar also ich
glaube jetzt sind das der dunlop band
mit dieser lage das hat die für bisschen
übertrieben aber es ist nicht zu
unterschätzen das thema das ich dass es
vorher noch mehr ausbreiten könnte eben
wenn wind auf käme und würde das feuer
mit glut und funken über diese zu
schaffen den schneisen in
übertreiben dann kann das zum problem
werden sagt dr jay leno brandexperte
vielen herzlichen dank ihnen für diese
information
[Musik]